all teams will have started their
offseason program other than the Saints
as of today you can read about the
ongoing offseason programs and much more
in Peter Kings football morning in
America including the Russell Wilson's
story and a hypothetical about what
happens if the Cardinals decide not to
take kala Merri with the first overall
pick in the draft so there are some of
the playoff teams getting back to work
this morning phase one of the off season
program everybody has 9 weeks it doesn't
matter when you start when you finish
you've got 9 total weeks and the Chiefs
are back at it today I'm told that
receiver Tyreke ill will be that
remember there was that issue that came
up a few weeks ago with the
investigation into a possible incident
of child abuse there's an issue with his
contract he had been discussing with the
team through his agent Drew Rosenhaus a
possible contract extension nothing has
gone anywhere with that one item of
leverage from him would be to stay away
from voluntary offseason workouts but he
will be present in Kansas City for the
start of that that workout session and
look I don't know where all this goes
it's been very quiet for the past
several weeks Chris but some ominous
possible allegations to be made against
Tyreke kill and that would that would
take a major toll on his football career
and ultimately his freedom if there is
some sort of of incident of child abuse
that is proven but for now it's just an
investigation that's all it's been for
the past several weeks and we'll see
where it goes but Tyree kill one of the
most effective and electric players in
the game and we'll be present today for
the offseason program yeah good I mean
he needs to be there he certainly he
can't be the guy that holds out right
now I mean I just don't think it's a
good look for them and and of course if
I'm the Kansas City Chiefs and you know
they're stalling I'm sure a little bit
on their contract negotiations or talks
because yeah okay sorry Tyreke we really
like you but there's this little issue
that came about you know the last few
weeks where of course there there was
that little issue with his son and and I
know he's not been charged but I'm sure
they want to let it play out make sure
they get all the facts and everything
before they get to two down you know the
conversation
of contract talks there tyree kill if he
does get totally exonerated in this and
nothing more comes of this I do think
he's gonna be in the conversation for
the highest paid receiver and all a
football he is the number one weapon in
the sport right now I don't think
there's any way of denying that I mean
when Tyree kill has the ball in his
hands
there's nobody in football that's more
apt to breaking a long touchdown or
making an explosive play he's a pretty
special talent and remember there was a
report at one point from Jay Glazer that
Tyreke Hills name had come up in
possible trade discussions which makes
you wonder is this a guy the Chiefs are
committed to long term now the the
ongoing investigation throws a wrench in
the the opportunity to trade him until
this is all worked out but I don't know
that it's guaranteed he's gonna be there
even if he is exonerated even if there
are no charges there are no issues there
is no suspension it could be the Chiefs
decide to get what they can for Tyreke
kill and move on well I mean maybe maybe
there's more to it than we don't know
but I think that's risky I really do but
the quarterback you have and you know
okay you got Sammy Watkins but man Sammy
Watkins the one thing we've learned
about him is he can't stay healthy I
mean that's the only thing we really
know about him and his career is that so
that to me and I still think Kansas City
overpaid Sammy Watkins but that to me
would be the big question if they you
know get rid of Tyree kill man this is
one of the this has the potential to be
one of the best combinations we've seen
in the history of football Tyree
Kilpatrick mahomes you know Patrick
mahomes arm talent of course scares
defenses as is when you add in a player
like Tyree kill who's in the
conversation for fastest guy in the
history in the NFL that only amplifies
mahomes arm and backs defenses off even
more to open everything else up so I I
think we're all said and done as long as
he gets exonerated here that Tyreke Hill
will be in Kansas City for a long time
well we'll see because at some point he
will have to be paid and he has every
right to expect based on his talent 20
million dollars or more per year because
when he is out there you have to pay
attention to him you have to account for
him and he can he can destroy the the
game plan defensively on any given
play especially because his speed forces
you between his speed and Pat mahomes
throwing ability you do have to cover
the entire field and we saw last year
how difficult that that is for a defense
when there isn't any area on that 100 by
53 yard surface that you can take for
granted when the Chiefs have the
football no well that's the the
greatness of any offense that's a top
quality top to your offense in the NFL
is they make you defend the entire field
so where defenses never get you know get
an never get a telltale sign of going
okay well if we defend this area you
know if we defend down the middle
you know Kansas City really likes to
attack that area we take a big part of
their offense away now no such thing
exists with this team you know with
mahomes ability to throw it anywhere
their ability to run the ball to which
hey I still wish they maybe ran the ball
a little bit more you know if you're
watching on TV you're watching Tyreke
Hill right now with a speed sweep you
know they make a defense cover the
horizontal part of the field with
screens and things like that - so Andy
Reed has found a good formula with Erik
sleeping with the enemy
as the offensive coordinator and of
course the talent do they have their
like I had a min there oh yeah that yeah
yeah I never heard that one before and
and I I it's amazing to me that the
enemy is still there - you look at Doug
Peterson going from Kansas City as
offensive coordinator coach the Eagles
Matt Nagy did the same thing the offense
was arguably better last year the
players raved about Eric the enemy he
didn't get much consideration about
that's good for the Chiefs it's good for
the Chiefs because they get another give
they get some continuity for a change
instead of this revolving door that's
been going on in Kansas City but the one
the one constant is Andy Reed as long as
he's I think the Chiefs are gonna be
pretty good especially since he has Pat
right we're done on NBCSN today enjoy
the Boston Marathon if you're watching
NBC SN if you're listening on NBC sports
radio we'll be back with the latest on
Nick Bosa more PFT labra Dennis
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports